the final six face-off tonight on
Dancing with the Stars there is a no
room for error now so how far will they
go to win well all across the country we
are tracking the stars a rehearsal for
New York City to Sin City
bhindi it's Broadway along with Derrick
mark and Alexa their trip to see Chicago
as part of a never before dancing twist
ever done a challenge like this on the
show but couples are teaming up to
perform a side-by-side routine inspired
by their travels oh that was the other
guy well bendy tries to perfect her jazz
hands in New York City Nick Sharna Val
and Tamar get ready to rumba in Vegas
by checking out the Beatles love Cirque
du Soleil show at the Mirage we have the
Beatles on our side and love on our side
I don't think you can't well maybe yeah
as long as they don't have to sing along
Hey Jude no what's it was it their
competition Carla's and Alec got the
vibes for their team Paso Doble bite
something bumper car and sort of
skydiving on the Royal Caribbean cruise
ship anthem of the Seas
you haven't really rehearse much with
she's kind of little tricky but hey yeah
right we're having a good time bill
dance suit we will rock you so they
caught the ships tribute show to Queen
we're getting closer and we got a dance
together for 45 seconds by ourselves
yep how do you feel about that it'll be
magical sparks will fly something
gorgeous will come out of it